what was Heath Ledger like to work with
fantastic just a really great guy my one
experience with Heath on the film was
our scene together in the hospital which
is really my only scene with him and I
was in the hospital bed that day and I
thought well I don't really have any
lines what am I going to do and I had no
idea what was going to happen so I was
got in the bed and they were lighting
and Chris was walking around and doing
things and then he came around and Heath
was always in character so he would come
around and you know be talking to
himself in the corner
like this and then he would come up I
was laying there and I was watching him
the whole time didn't say anything for
maybe an hour and then we'd watch him
and then he'd start saying his lines
watch him come around to bed like this
and then all of a sudden my hands would
go up like this and he caught my hand so
we just went through this organic
process of developing this scene which
was really nothing and then when we came
time to shoot we had this thing
beautifully choreographed and you know
he did we never said a word to each
other wow yeah and then it was a long
day and we walked out back to our
trailers and Heath was here and I was
walking and he puts his hand on my
shoulder and he goes that's what
acting's all about